I'm Brittany.
I'm 18 and I live in Florida in the USA.
Almost every day, I read the latest science news and research advances...
...because it is so exciting to see the breakthroughs being made.
I became fascinated by an article on artificial intelligence,...
...and I decided to learn how to program.
Coding was a real challenge and it took a few attempts to get it to work.
Back when I was little, I really grew to idolize the men and women in scrubs...
...who were using science every day to save lives.
My brother was born premature and we spent a lot of time in the hospital for his first few years.
Then when I was 15, my cousin was diagnosed with breast cancer...
...and I saw firsthand the impact it has on a woman and her family.
I decided I wanted to make a difference...
...by trying to make the experience a little bit better for those involved.
I was able to teach the computer how to diagnose breast cancer...
...by making it think like the brain to detect patterns far too complex for humans to recognize.
This means it could determine if a breast mass is malignant or benign.
It's really important because the least invasive test for breast cancer...
...is also the least conclusive.
Most doctors refuse to use these biopsies.
If they could be used, it could lead to earlier detection and a better process for the patient.
I spent hundreds upon hundreds of hours researching for over two years,...
...creating a neural network tool for doctors to use when analyzing results.
When the application actually diagnosed masses successfully, it was very exciting.
It diagnoses over ninety-nine percent of cancer patients correctly.
And since it is deployed as a cloud service,...
...it has the potential to be accessed by any hospital in the world.
It has been amazing to see how people, including cancer survivors,...
...are responding to my program and its potential.
Cancer touches all of us, and unfortunately, the rates are rising.
Helping find the cure to cancer is a real goal of mine,...
...and one day, I would love to be working on breakthroughs that can save lives.